not long ago a GTI a former Verizon
lawyer and anti net neutrality dude was
appointed as FCC Chairman I told you net
neutrality is in danger Trump doesn't
know what it is but he's against it
which is often the case with Trump
taking very strong positions on issues
he knows very little about just a couple
of weeks later
now the republican-controlled FCC has
voted to roll back some aspects of net
neutrality regulations specifically the
ones that required Internet service
providers to be transparent with their
customers they voted two to one to
remove for five years basically they're
suspending for five years a rule which
obligated smaller Internet service
providers if they have under two hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers they no
longer have to number one explain their
pricing models and fees to customers and
they no longer have to tell customers
whether they're tapping bandwidth for
certain websites and services think
about that this isn't some burdensome
regulation that ISPs have to go above
and beyond in order to meet just tell
your customers what you're charging and
how much bandwidth you get to use on
certain websites this will actually
apply to the vast majority of ISPs
there's only 20 Internet service
providers in the US with over 250,000
customers and here's the real trick this
rule applies to subsidiaries of larger
ISPs and there are many large ISPs that
have split their businesses from a legal
perspective into subsidiaries each of
which may have under 250 thousand
customers so it actually does allow some
of the really big Internet service
providers to skirt this requirement FCC
Commissioner minion Clyburn said in an
ongoing quest to dismantle basic
consumer protections for broadband
services the majority has decided to
exempt billion-dollar public companies
from being transparent with consumers
this represents yet another in a series
of steps being taken to jettison
pro-consumer
initiatives this might actually end up
making no difference in the sense that
now that we have Trump appointed FCC
Chairman Ajit PI and congressional
Republicans hoping to overturn all of
net neutrality this might end up being
sort of small potatoes
if you scrap the entire thing well I
think it's also good that this is
getting attention now in the public eye
because if you remember quite a few
years back the SOPA and PIPA Act yes
that went through Congress that
similarly tried to crack down on
Internet freedom right they looked like
they were going to pass right away but
people started calling up their Congress
people demanding that it was not going
to pass and it ended up not getting
passed this would be a different
approach because of course the FCC so
they don't have to hear directly from
the people right but they you have a
comment line and people can still
activate around the FCC yeah and people
are very passionate about this issue
once they get to learn about it and most
people are going to be against this
ajit pie saying that this is great
because we're not going to force
internet service providers to spend
money in order to meet burdensome
requirements bla bla bla
this is a typical right-wing tactic
point to burdensome Washington but the
reality is Obama's White House Office of
Management and Budget found that four
ISPs to comply with these regulations
these disclosure regulations it only
demanded about seven total labor hours
per year seven hours per year absolutely
not burdensome consumers should have the
right to know when their internet
traffic is being throttled how their
internet bill breaks down everything
about Trump's administration was going
to be about fighting for consumers right
apparently not not here I'd be willing
to do these seven regulation hours for
free as long as we can keep these
regulations Pat willing to volunteer
time to help out the overly burdened
huge Internet service providers